歡迎回到趙華
今天的大來賓
每一次來啊
其實都會創造非常好的收視率跟流量
而且他是我們兩個的啟蒙恩師
雖然他沒有想承認這件事情
但是他就是
有啦 後來有一次這位來賓有承認說
你是他的大弟子 突然有一次
開心了一下子 對
其實他可能只是
場面話
我們現在歡迎他出場
就是我們的K線之聲
朱家弘 朱老師
嗨 大家好
最近股市的震盪比較大
沒錯
所以如果短線上
大家覺得有挫折的朋友
真的要學一下
朱老師的精神 對不對
古海是一個長遠的路
對
所以今天很特別
朱老師要獨家來教一個
其實幾年前
他有在我們的單元
叫表股在線等
有提供過
就是有一個所謂的
叫戰日誌
每天要寫一下做功課
这个很基本
那今天有很多是回后买
也有一些是抢反弹的
到底该怎么做
形态就要看起来
好 高手怎么养成
朱老师盘前的必做功课
我们来告诉大家
有一张表格
好 这个是我当初
开始学技术分析的时候
那学完了之后
每天就
这个都是我自己设计的
就是我每天根据我学的东西
认为
你應該每天要看的一些資料
那大部分人就去看資料了
可是我就把它做成一個表格
那強迫自己去寫
你看完可能就忘了
那寫的話最後還有一個最重要
會有一個綜合研判
這就是練習
把資料轉換成對大盤的
我們台股大盤的看法
那經過很長一段時間的練習
你就會培養對大盤的盤感
熱騰騰的
今天早上盤前剛寫好的日子
長這個樣子
一般來說我們9點開盤
如果你早上8點半
你把整個的資料看一下
那最主要因為
每股要早上才能看
那你如果前天晚上有空
那你這些可以前天晚上先寫
包括那我就來舉一個範例
那這個寫的日子
是來判斷今天的大盤
寫完是可以判斷的
對
所以這是昨天大盤收完牌
你就把所有的資料寫一下
它是漲
然後漲了多少點
漲幅是多少
這個你都給它稍微的寫完
那寫完了之後
當然我這邊有列兩個指標
因為我們技術分析裡面
也會學指標
那這個指標也會讓你做研判
我们的大盘目前是一个多空
还是一个短线的低档的反弹
这个都可以在指标上看得出来
那早期我比较有空
最近因为实在很忙了
那我都会有做棋子当冲
所以这个是给做棋子当冲人去填的
棋子这边有个棋子
如果你要做棋子
因为这两张图是不一样的
数字也不一样
所以你做棋子就去填这个位置
那我先講一下
那邊有個大事記
大事記要記什麼
大事記就是今天有發生
跟股票有關的一些新聞
比如說前一陣子說
這個零股要改變
這個時間什麼都要改變
那你這邊可以寫一下
這個國家的政策
每一要開戰
對 每一開戰
或者是聯準會要升息
那這些我們都知道很重要
甚至于台积电的法说会
你也可以写今天是法说会
然后它的大致上的重点
这个就是属于大事记
那这是便于你以后回头来查
回头来查资料
好那在这边呢
我们先讲这几个板块
那这一块包括到何记
到何记
那这个三大法人的买卖超
投信外资自营商
所以你很清楚地看到
昨天外资是卖超的
但是金额很少
为什么要你每天写
因为你每天写才知道它的变化
如果你一个礼拜再写一下
说不定昨天是大买的
你都不知道
所以我们要每天写
我们就知道昨天
合计是买超162亿
所以另外也知道
外资好像没有卖那么凶
对 卖比较少了
前面都是几百亿
还有上千亿卖的
不过昨天大涨他还卖
也可以知道这件事
OK 至少我们也知道
投信还有自营商都买
我们的类资都买
好 那下面就是融资融卷的变化
这很重要
所以我们又可以看到
昨天好像融资又增加了不少
74亿
是 还好
因为昨天大涨
对
所以这个也是每天写
你就会知道
融资一路增加或者减少
那最後當然這個叫做
融券跟融券一二
那昨天掌也有一些融券的增加
那這一塊就是
這個三大法人的期貨單
他們的期貨單
從這邊可以看
自營商手上留的是多單
這是當天的多空單的增減
那投信多单有七万五千多口
那当然外资从八万多
现在减到七万八嘛
那其实从这里看一下
我们的内资加起来
也是八万多口
是
对不对
所以看起来外资你会很害怕
哇七八万口
不会啊
因为我们的内资也有七万口
是
所以这个可以平衡一下
不要说你只看一方面
就像我們的買賣超一樣
你光看外資會嚇死了
可是你看那支也都在買
表示那支在互盤
這裡有個五大交易人
跟十大交易人的期貨單
還有五大特定法人
十大特定法人的期貨單
這是全市場留的期貨單全市場這個是要看它是一路增加了还是我们的流仓去减少那这些资料因为软体不一样
还有券商的软体不同
那如果这个观众想要去做的话
有可能有些资料你找不到
那你就问你的营业员
因为券商营业员最清楚
我们家软体哪个在哪里
当然三大法人
期交所每天都一定会
故地公布还蛮好找
差不多都有
这些期交所都可以找到
好那这一块就是美股
因为美股到底还是现在
影响全世界的
所以我们就看到
昨天的美股四大指数都涨的
尤其肺半
肺半涨了5%
這個蠻多的
當然這個表格是我個人用的
那也是很久以前
十幾年前
那現在可能每個同學或者朋友
你可以增加你想要知道的
你想說那我再增加一行什麼
台積電的ADR也可以
你每天就可以看
台積電ADR是漲是跌
那這些資料你每天看完了
其实最重要就是培养这个
你要做一个研判
我们看到那么多数据
到底今天大盘好还是不好
好 这在风险就写下来了
对 写什么
这个就是最重要
美股四大指数都上涨
那台股昨天是成型转折
我们台股昨天也是反弹
那今天美股又大涨
所以基本上
那昨天因为亮说
今天只要放量续反弹
但是向上有个月线压力
所以我们的月线
大概是45,378
所以各位可以看一下
我们今天盘中的高点
就谈到这里
45,378
45,373,370
就谈到这里
这就是我们先判好
也就是说
我知道今天会涨
但是到这里你不要追
你不要开高跑这边来追
那这边就是压
这个就是你每天写
你對盤感事先就有掌握了
你也知道今天還會漲
昨天是反彈
那今天會漲
那如果我們再延伸一下
那大家可以練習一下
今天晚上你再把這些資料寫一寫
不一樣每天都會變的
才要寫嘛 不能偷懶
對 不能偷懶
你叫別人寫最後別人是高手
你還是不會
因為寫的人話每天
我記得華爾街有一個超版高手
就是超黑版出來的
是 好
那大家如果有訂閱我們
趙華艾倫說的YouTube頻道
剛剛那一張
我們會在首頁的貼文欄
也會放在那邊讓大家做下載
好的 對
好 載採
好 有新人嘛
你自然就會去做了
那我剛剛有講
你甚至於還可以增加
自己想要知道的欄位
是 那這樣子
我想三個月以後
你就會有感覺了
有感觉了
当然你要练到很熟
可能就继续学嘛 继续学
好 那我们刚才的这个
对大盘的研判就在这个地方
第一个它昨天是一个诚心转折
那昨天这边是黄金交叉
MACD已经接近零轴了
在长期多头里面接近零轴
是很容易反弹的
它这边很容易就会反弹
所以我们都是根据技术分析
去做今天的研判
所以今天就剛好碰到月線就下來
那同樣的
大家也練習一下
研判一下明天
朱老師現在先跟我們講明天
因為外資還沒有
沒有 因為美股還沒有開
還有一些數字可能還沒有出來
所以你要晚上再去把它查一查
再來做一些研判
但是最重要一個叫趨勢
所以我剛剛有寫叫反彈
反彈欲壓是很容易反應的
跟多頭不一樣
多頭鍵壓不是壓
它很容易過
但空頭鍵壓你就要小心
它經常都會有壓力
這就是你慢慢地做
寫久了你就會懂了
好 所以今天真的反彈到
月線遇到一個壓力
對 好 所以有驗證
早上朱老師的判斷對不對
然後當然做完結論
我們要鎖股
我們看到大盤可能是有壓力
可是類股怎麼說呢
對 這個其實是
這個才是我怎麼講
散戶要把股票做好
這個要做好
是
那我一直跟大家講
我們散戶的資源比較少
雖然我們剛剛去
把一些資訊都知道
但這些資訊都公開的
大家都知道的
對不對
但是最重要就是
要選到好股票
那怎麼樣選
我們最簡單的方法
就是在收盤前
原則上如果你能看盤
收盤前
對 因為有些人
可能沒辦法看盤
如果你可以看盤的話
12點鐘你就開始
去看盤裡面的強勢股
那什麼叫強勢股
就是漲幅的排行榜
都漲停啊 朱老師
對 就從漲停排
到9% 到8% 到7%
那就看當天的強弱
其實我們那天大碟
漲停的只有幾家
其他都很少
不是每天
因為今天很強
剛好遇到反彈
所以很多
這個強速股的排名
有幾個重點
第一個
當然這裡面的股票
一定要多投的股票
因為有很多是反彈
對啊
所以你不要看到漲停
它是反彈
所以第一個它要多投股票
那第二個
這些多投股票
你抓下來了以後
就要看位置了
如果它剛好已經漲三四天
那你就等它拉回
這個就是不要追高
意思就是不要追高
但它卻是很好的股票
因為它大盤還是空頭
它居然多頭還漲
還漲到高點
那表示這個很強
那你就把它留下來
那如果還有一個是底部剛剛反轉
我今天看到紅K
哇 多頭確認了
而且均線也做好
那我們就去鎖股
那这个锁骨有的时候会稍微等一等比如说均线还没做好但它是多頭那我們就擺在邊上所以你如果自己會找股票
基本上你有時候會找到底部
轉強的股票
那在這個台面上
可能還沒有人去談它
對不對 因為很多股票
都底部偷偷的在漲
對不對 沒錯
但是你已經知道了
你就可以锁它了
等到哪一天它转强
你就可以开始操作
那第三个这个叫做空头转强
叫破切
长期都空头
但是比如说我们这几天
有很多涨停板的
那你看它有没有破切
有破切又是原来有题材的类股
那表示这里它可能要开始反转
因为它已经跌够了
我们刚才有讲很多股票
都跌了1%了
500都跌到200了
那这时候如果有大量红可以这样破切
你也可以追踪
不过这个可能是摆在最后
因为它还要做底嘛
你可能摆在最后
那你每天去看这里面
都会有符合这些的股票
那你找出来了以后
这个就建一个锁股的资料夹
然后你去稍微的排序
因为有的是这个嘛
有的刚好回档
也許明天就可以買了
所以你排序一下
你準備要買的股票
可能明後天要發動的
你就擺在最前面
然後這樣
另外你再篩選一下
比如說我講這個破切
可能還要一段時間
你暫時也可以不要拉進來
這些比較優先的擺在前面
那第三個重點
不要抱太多的鎖股
你不要鎖五六十檔
你鎖五六十檔到時候
你就很难觉得我到底要买哪一支
所以你锁完了股票以后
请你自己觉得哪个最强
比如说哪个题材
现在要发酵的
或者业绩很好的
那你就大概把它精选
那原则上我建议大家不要超过20档
不要超过20档也不少
手上15档到20档
因为有的要等嘛
还要回来嘛
你大概
然后你就专心在你锁的股里面
等機會
你不要再看別的了
你手上已經是很好的股票了
你手上的股票
有兩三檔讓你一直做
你的獲利就已經很好了
這個就是我們要把精神集中
在現在的強勢股
另外你每天看這個強勢股
還有一個好處
你會發現本來很弱的
天天跌著股票
比如說我們講被動元件
今天怎麼都漲停板
这个类股好像又要复活了
对嘛 因为你看就知道
这个也是被动
哇 那这个又可以了
对不对
这个就是你在强势股里面看
是不是有同一个性质的股票
出现了很多档
那表示它转强
好 因为大家可能想要的
还是这种已经有回过了
对不对
或者是已经在比较低位阶的
所以這邊的話 鎖股名單列出來
我們就把今天收盤的強制股
那我剛剛講12點看
你有一個準備盤前
如果剛好今天發動
那你盤前1點 1點20
你就可以進場了
你說收盤前就進場了
對啊 因為你12點就在找這些
那12點為什麼不能去進
因為12點還沒有收盤
你排漲停板的
可能12點半就下來了
它打開了
它打開啦
所以你大概先挑
這幾個都今天回後買上漲
那你就等 等到一點 一點十分
還是沒有下來 還是很好
那之後你就可以進場
不過這邊的話
觀眾朋友常常問這個問題
就是說莊老師我等著等著
就要12點以後漲停了
早知道我就之前先買
那個是高手的牌
那個以後有空再來講
大家還是遵循這件事
好 哇 這邊很多
供應電腦的化漢 對不對
這個偽創今天漲停板
精彩之強是股
藍亞 中美金華碩
這邊有很多股票
有個觀念
如果你到1.20
漲停的就不要買了
就算了
我剛剛有講
你10幾檔股票
你不要每支都做
那這裡有沒有漲停的
漲6%的 漲5%的
像藍亞今天就是
今天就買點了
今天
對啊
那你不是1.20就可以買了嗎
是
对啊 你找到了 一支啊
那这些有些你要等什么
还要等盘整突破
还要等明天
这是昨天发动
昨天就已经发动
有的还要等拉回
还要确认
对 你就把它摆在手上
是
你没有等到的你就等
那假如你是收盘以后才看
那你就可以看明天会不会涨的
明天会涨的
你就开盘就锁了
是 好
那我们这边广海来举例了
大家一定很想知道
最好是鎖了谁 鎖谁
对嘛
华硕昨天是多头确认
昨天吗
昨天它涨的一定在强势股
因为它昨天涨的好像七八%
所以它在强势股
这只怎么变多了
你看前面900跌到600了
昨天要找到华硕没有那么简单
因为昨天有75当涨停的样子
不会 它也在
因为它只留一点点的上
它也涨很多
对 它昨天涨很多
OK了
所以你会找到它
那如果你是在
昨天收盘前就看到了
那你买今天
OK了
今天已经开始获利了
那你做隔日冲就卖
你要做波段
你就沿着五军报
就沿着五军
对不对
就很操作很简单
好 那我们刚刚讲
伪创
伪创这支股票
昨天你如果有看到的话
它昨天是多头
还真没想到
這也是昨天多頭
看到沒有
可是昨天多頭不能做
因為它在月線下
它不符合我們做
這個在月線上
要在月線上
對 這個可以
這個在月線季線上
那這個昨天是不可以做
因為它在月線下 季線下可是你可以鎖它你一鎖你今天就發現開盤就上均線那就表示很強它一開盤就跑到均線上
而且它的季線月線都向上了
它沒有向下
所以開盤你鎖著如果它往上
你一樣今天就不會等漲停板
你就買到了
可是今天如果我還是遵守在這個
所謂收盤前它就已經漲到嗎
那你就要做剛才
我们所没有涨停的股票
很像嘛
所以基本上啦
你如果没有做它
你可以留在手上啊
我刚刚讲不要忘了
这个明天再涨
后天就做拉回嘛
下次拉回就是你的股票啦
就是一只很好的股票
其实这只股票明天才是关键
怎么说
这个压力要过啊
来到压力区了
明天一过啊
回后你就买
就很有把握了
它已經連山紅了嘛
又有放量嘛
那就表示這個底是真的是底
不是假的
這些底都沒有量
所以你在這裡買很容易失敗的
這個以後慢慢分享
下次來講一下量
對 量價的關係
因為剛剛我們講了很多
好多觀眾朋友也會有一個誤解
他都會說跌了
現在上漲不就叫做回後買上漲嗎
事實上朱老師的名言
不只朱老師用
好多人在用
好多人在用的話
我們一定要讓觀眾朋友知道
回後買上漲是有定義的
對 正確版本
不是跌了上漲
就叫回後買上漲
它有一定的條件
所以任何時候你要買股票
都要把條件先列出來
也就是我們所謂的檢查項
回後買上漲
第一個多頭回就是回檔
所以多頭回檔的時候
一定要记得
什么叫回后买上涨
第一个没有破前面的低点
它并没有把
我回档的时候
没有把前面这个低点跌破
这是最重要的
一跌破你就不能买了
你买几乎都会赔钱的
好 那第二个还不要跌破月线
在月线上
因为月线会给你支撑
你买了就容易涨
那第三个出现大量红K的上涨
所以這個是重點
你要買上漲
回後買上漲
那很多人說
跌三天可不可以買
他就買回後
跌五天又在問
老師可不可以買
還沒有上漲啊
所以回後買上漲
這個上漲就是紅K
那它要什麼條件
它要突破五日均線
它要上漲站上五日均線
還要過昨天的最高點
这个都在帮助你
买了不容易停损
容易成功
这也代表它转强了
我又可以站上五军
又把昨天的高点突破
因为昨天的高点是压力
为什么不然昨天为什么不涨
为什么在这里就下来了
所以那个是压力
这些条件都符合
就是最好的买的位置
所以第一个要多头
每次上涨
我们刚才讲
你不是强制股選了一支股票嗎
它漲三四天
那你就等回
然後不要破前提
然後紅K上漲
這個叫回後買上漲
那如果是底部追蹤的股票
往往一支股票
你大概有兩或三次的機會
做到回後買上漲
就是有一波 兩波 三波
那如果你三波都能夠把握
隨便加一加也十幾% 二十%
這個獲利很高的
很多人回後買上漲
會誤解說那就是100%要賺錢
但是它還是有一些機率
可能會失敗
當然
所以出場點停損點要放在哪裡
好 很簡單
回後買上漲
你買就設好停損
你有兩種方法
一個用固定停損
就是5%
我們如果固定停損
100塊跌破95
那你就要買
那如果沒有停損
那就恭喜了
你就開始了
就像這個華碩
剛才華碩第二天了
那你就沿著五軍做
那這是做短線
像我們剛才有大盤的日誌
你就知道大盤線在反彈
所以你做股票不要做長線
你就做短線
要不然大盤又殺下去
你的股票長線也賺不到錢
所以你掌握好你自己的方法
然後按照紀律去做
你久了久了
你就會掌握這個獲利的方法
好 這邊的話
也幫大家舉例
這一看就是強勢股
如果它都已經漲了好幾波
我還能做嗎
這個是跳空漲停
所以當天你在強勢股就看到它
會看到它 不是今天看到
前面就看到了 跳空漲停
如果你在這邊鎖 回後買上漲
這個回檔 回後買上漲
現在回檔 昨天是回後買上漲
你這幾波都有賺
只是有时候赚多 有时候赚少
好 那蓝亚呢
你如果在前面
这也叫强势股
对不对
这也是涨停板
那你就锁
回来了
回后买上涨
然后跌破五均卖
今天回后买上涨
所以蓝亚科
如果你今天
蓝亚
如果你前面就锁住的
我刚讲你会有一波两波
好几波可以做
那你今天收盘前
哎呦 它又来了
因為在你的20黨裡面
你20黨就有它
那你自然今天就是好的進場位置
好 看起來畫得都好容易
進場 進場 進場
可是我們好像都是追高追高追高
殺低 殺低 殺低
那個是我們人性
都喜歡追高殺低
但是你稍微的克制一下
因為你要在股市賺錢
你總要有一些
這些忍耐的地方
所以忍耐是我們成功操板手
一個最重要的一個特質
你一定要能夠忍耐
不要去追考就好
今天很謝謝朱老師
謝謝
朱老師其實是我們的常客
沒錯
那每一次教學都還是有新的體悟
因為像最近在反彈
大家可能就要辨別
到底是空頭反彈
還是真的恢復多頭的格局
這些都延續性
後面的延續性
都很值得大家來做推敲的
對
好 那大家如果想要日志的話
就是把趙華恩人說的YouTuber
訂閱起來